mas para que se eventualmente olá amigos
gostar se quer fazer aqui uma pequena
renda fixa não sai mas são 204 países
para vocês não conta não é relevante não
era o melhor do vitor tem 50 anos sou o
pai
subo lista suas portas em listas são
logo disciplinado e definir exatamente
como uma pessoa assim mesmo é
comunicação faz parte dos meus caminhos
e pelos meus 30 anos do mundo é e estou
aqui estou aqui para dar um pouco
convosco sobre viagens e no fundo sobre
aquilo que nem mexe na alma que o mundo
é que é o mundo que nós deveríamos
aprender e deveremos ter mundo é ao
contrário dos outros jogadores e eu não
não não quero estar aqui é da pesquisa
da revista você já estão aqui há duas
horas portanto queria que cria não quero
que seja um intercâmbio não sei se já
foi não sei se é possível fazer mas eu
vou fazer eu já fiz algumas tv que se
nos açores em lisboa e queria fazê lo é
não vai aqui também falar sobre mim um
pouco falar sobre o que eu fiz que é uma
grande diferença entre aquilo que eu fiz
e que eu sou é começar por exemplo para
explicar a partilhar convosco é o que eu
acho sobre a viagem o que eu acho sobre
o mundo e o que eu acho sobre tudo isso
é que nós devemos fazer nas nossas vidas
e que o que eu fiz quando era pequenino
é que nós somos aquilo em que
acreditamos que isso não somos devemos
ser nós quando somos aquilo em que
acreditamos três anos um caso de um
caminho
criamos objetivos e step by step e
atingimos o nosso ponto final fez o que
eu fiz quando tinha 17 anos e resolve
rezar é e no dia 11 11 11
terminei todos os países do mundo têm um
certo orgulho poder ter feito isso com
uma pessoa portuguesa portugal e depois
porque atinge os meus novos objetivos em
conseguir estar em todos os países não é
tarefa fácil
é mas está feito hoje em dia que o que
eu faço basicamente a textura e as
palestras e no fundo linhas
motivacionais
além do workshop de fotografia
e também já fiz perto de 700 gramas
totalizando us sobre viagens a trabalho
é não vou jogar nenhuma bola mas quem é
a pessoa mais nova que continua a mesma
quantia que vai chegar fosse o último
é mesmo conteúdo não tenho vergonha
disse uma coisa é qual é o nome vasco
vive uma coisa eu acho qual é esse o
princípio gostaria de visitar não
perguntar a tomar é o teu pai ele mesmo
até o país desde a colônia é muito bem e
tem aí o que queria se encontrar na
polônia
olha é minha opinião e aquilo que eu
posso dizer que existe duas cidades que
são fortíssimos universal via outra copa
propostas perceberam os buy coimbra
cracóvia uma cidade ao sul da cidade
como a linha diferente mais ligado aos
estudantes mas resolve é um crime mais
grave
assim eu posso dizer portanto quando
estiverem na polônia fórum carinho de
ver sobe e vai te krakoff por cada qual
vai se sentir muito mais dentro daquele
espírito estudantil de coimbra e até
braga não esqueças vasco quando tiver 18
anos depois que seus pais
o inter ganhou pra fazer essa viagem não
esqueça a copa certamente é deixar de
falar um pouco sobre a minha experiência
na amazônia
eu vivi cinco anos na amazônia ceamazon
recomenda o meu filho anos é o que é
índio e é luciana e completamente ter
vivido na amazônia e por que que dois
anos numa piroga e como vocês imaginam
estar dois anos é insights de box é por
isso que eu estou aqui no inside box é
objetivar tudo isso foi uma tarefa
extremamente difícil é mas jamais vai
aprender e aprender essas coisas aprendi
por exemplo a linha xamânica do
ayahuasca e à ré e outras linhas muito
semelhantes muito interessante aprender
a perceber como dizem a pouco nós somos
aquilo em que acreditamos realmente fato
existente santos que eu lembro quando
era pequenino
aliás o meu último livro que me faça
nada exatamente isso é quando eu ia com
a minha volta no lumiar e ea caminhar
tranquilamente e nunca imaginadas de
visitar todos os países
vocês não imaginam
é enorme interessa que te visitar todos
os países do mundo então eu acho que o
que me faz andar e como quem diz faça
andar eu aprendi na amazônia
durante os meus dois anos entre olga que
consegui perceber que nós temos um
potencial e no domicílio por vezes não
imaginamos é o potencial que nós temos e
e eles não têm a ver com a amazônia mas
também como diz o budista e uma vez uma
das minhas linhas do disney naiana e e
linha onde eu aprendi mais foi enviada a
sá que é a linha vi passando pra vocês
percebam que é uma língua de introspeção
nós temos durante semanas sem parar numa
de introspecção ou seja é que os
recomendo sempre quero fazer uma viagem
o que recomendo é a vossa vida
profissional é que faça uma introspeção
daqui que querem e nunca se esqueçam de
uma coisa
o importante é sermos aquilo que
queremos o que não queremos aprender é
fácil eu já sei o que não quer agora eu
quero todos os dias tem que ir
aprendendo
foi isso e foi por isso que eu ia sair
para conhecer em viagem é pra conhecer
culturas completamente diferentes para
interpretar a linguagem completamente
diferentes das pessoas da amazônia ter
visitado se você tirar dalai lama por
exemplo testado é reserva em 1995 ter
vindo da indonésia o mês de maio e
basicamente continuar onde outros todo o
tempo que é uma escola de vida quanto a
minha aprendizagem entre povos e
culturas completamente diferentes
e foi isso essa sido viagem é cedo de
poder perceber como é que se vive no
irão como é que se vive na micronésia
alguém por aqui sabe qual é o país mais
clean do mundo por exemplo certamente
vou aprender alguma coisa comigo
qual é o país mais clean do mundo alguém
a idéia vai ter uma visão estava
completamente diferente um país mais
pequeno do mundo vocês querem ouviram
falar chama ipca alan tem 47 pessoas eu
lado da micronésia e são todos da mesma
família em santíssimo
por acaso quando estava na nova zelândia
fipe carne tem chá branco onde só nos
estágios mais interessantes do mundo
tenta aprender alguma coisa nova pican é
um país interessante
pergunta celina que é o cantinho da sala
malek ale como salame é consigo rolou
para achá-lo siga chute de gum digão
você o que quer que eu dê sem ser o
início e quer falar em que país em que
continente quer falar sobre essa
oportunidade para partilhar consigo
minha opinião é o meu peixe frito porque
eu gosto da indonésia tem uma multa e
cultura indústria paulista e ao mesmo
tempo também muçulmana costa da
indonésia que o turismo na indonésia é
um turismo barato preço qualidade nós
olharmos por exemplo o hospital é bem
leve enem em bauru e pagamos três euros
se olharmos para uma refeição pagamos um
erro em maio
depois quem gosta de servir como eu sou
branquinho vocês podem ver portanto
tarefa surfar nas ondas seja o ato ou
até mesmo ambiental ae
dá nos a oportunidade poderemos viajar é
e podia estar a ser fácil agora como é
que chegam a ser uma forma barata é
muito simples voltar aqui duas três
pastores raramente saímos de lisboa
neste momento por exemplo vou viajar
para a indonésia novamente em dezembro e
para que percebam não devemos ir de
lisboa cml londres e não vamos pretende
passar o tempo passar e capital que se
chama bola e nós vamos para de carta
qual lumpur ou até mesmo de cingapura
então vejamos o voo londres 400 e 450
euros porque cingapura não citando as
pessoas vão passar férias depois temos
um sítio interessante se quer fazer as
companhias low cost que vai de saltar e
dizia que é neste caso de cingapura onde
o aluno por exemplo a exigência faz
bolsas cingapura é ter valem 100 euros e
de volta como nós fazemos com nossa
exigência em lisboa a um exame ou seja
nós conseguimos ver a indonésia por 500
anos tranquilamento 500 600 crianças e
minha namorada vai permanecer dentro de
uma semana e eu comprei um bilhete com
625 euros nessa altura que a crise
portanto indonésias e 150 euros não é
muito caro
depois ficar lá 34 dias devemos ficar em
allston se que muitos deles porque o
sócio porque eu gosto dos tons vai
voltar na obscuridade não estava
num quarto com três camas ou duas camas
com inglês com francesa e um belga e uma
crise era exatamente isso vamos esquecer
as prisões douro
as pulseirinhas dodô não sei onde está
há 18 anos infectados em cuneo e dizer
que teremos algum tive no méxico ao
méxico mas que nem sequer que vocês
tiveram que ver em uma praia empacotados
como sebastião apanhar haver um gol de
josiel se case sem avisar onde nós
queremos viajar devemos primeiro que
tudo está com os locais em segundo lugar
e desculpa viajar sozinhos nós temos luz
temos 15 de junho não somos mais que
animais de habituação
se vocês pensarem fundamentos somos
exatamente isso não se habituou anos
atuando seguidamente quando viajamos
sozinho vou usar um exemplo estamos na
china com a nossa amiga mariana
mariana fala português país queira falar
português para a direita e tudo que é em
volta de nós e circuito santo
se não estivermos sozinhos o primeiro
dia 11 horas e dias somos obrigados a
abrir nos da cultura em dízimos na
cultura estamos considerando os locais e
as pessoas locais e sequer viajaram
não é como um turista que faz 7 37 e
lava e eu feliz da vida a ela new york
ontem dizia um amigo meu por nova york
não passa de uma amadora mas não tenho a
mínima dúvida
se olharmos aquilo da produção grande
exatamente isso não tenho a mínima
dúvida
agora vamos dizer não aqui está honrando
as calorias e tá kwai vamos a terceira
pergunta a última pergunta eu quero
fechar isso outra forma
vou aqui deixando só apanhar alguém
compareça roquete é desconexas mas sim
maria joão vamos travar uma das viagens
que eu fiz mais interessante joão pra
áfrica foi fazer lisboa nigéria comeu
jeito eu vou te contar uma pequena
história
eu sou sportinguista e quando o sporting
que foi jogar com a taça de portugal e
com o campeonato nacional eu resolvi
sair da amazônia em vender o obstante
center que é um centro de energias
alternativas e vir para a europa o
sporting que foi a taça uefa prazer
foi com carne pra eu ligasse e agora o
que eu faço nada melhor que é meu jipe
land rover discovery que detalhe foi
diretamente a nigéria livros que foi
especial joão é é viagem que eu fiz
dentro do meu jipe até a nigéria é
interessante pela mauritânia que é que
eu vou contar a história que é o leasing
é depois avancei e pelo senegal é
guiné-bissau é que 77 mas que a
fronteira da mauritânia que usava sempre
complicado eo valor dos medicamentos do
doctor bordo médicos sem fronteiras
empresário é na guiné bissau eu tinha um
satélite em órbita a esta parte que está
aqui está pra senhora existem aquelas
pílulas e talat o tudo vê lá então eu
cheguei afronta e thala o momento
salamaleque uma vive o seu cronômetro as
pessoas devem marrocos na semana passada
deve ser candidato com este programa
resumindo e concluindo eu cheguei nisso
aí tá tudo ok distinto mau mau não vão
tomar de volta à itália história meu
grito é que não tem nada aproveitam este
som e são essas que eu fui mesmo as
pílulas e toucinho ouvir algumas 4 11 18
meses e que quando o filho então
investir porque o frio ou mesmo era o
mesmo aquelas devia servir esse tipo de
imóvel e que o caminho não é moda mas é
assim y que são essas
estas situações que nós encontramos em
viagem depois agora no senegal
nessa viagem da mãe áfrica aliás de 23
anos e madagáscar também meu pai disse
que eu falar em espécie ou falar que eu
vou pro cacilheiro e volks não é pra mim
sinceramente falar sobre viagens e muito
além das coisas que eu mais gosto é o
que eu mais gosto que eu gosto da
fotografia eu sou fotógrafo fez que eu
amo mesmo que a luz mas falar sobre
viagens é uma coisa muito interessante
joão voltando então a ser legal eu
cheguei à fronteira dos legal e comigo
meu jipe o meu jipe é tinha mais de 15
anos e carros com mais de 15 anos não
passou não deixam passar ficam prevê
vender pra cá se auto profere eo mundo
em santo ver o carro da cmm aconselha
recebia cachê tarde mohamed já estava
com ser diferente eu salame betal sido
ganho exemplo jogaram na voz de mourinho
é muito bom e que o youtube
empreender vieram com vocês vão ver com
115 uma média em todo mundo tenso então
né eu lá pra sair juntas a holandesa de
muito primitivo
assim como eu queria como é não é uma
caravana que levará tinha pai 20 anos já
imagino xl muito primitivos e tão tão
distante mas passa então tudo mais claro
não deixou passar em branco porque isso
aqui com mais 50 euros e nos gols é tão
falando é que é isso que fazemos
distinção entre eles engenheiros de que
os dois eu 2009 mas muito o máximo que
posso ajudar e fazemos estado shan são
seis da tarde
portanto vamos resolver isso cicinho
está nas copas após o título de anjo
retorno a chance como sabem sempre o
caminho
olha aí os dois passaportes que ela está
aqui para fazer o teste em fazer um
disco sim porque assim ele vai ficar sem
os meus 10 não tem que dar 20 de ipi
também que fica 80 eo ganho nos 80 anos
em 19 dos 26 80 que os seus você
trabalhar aqui mas quem vocês não estão
vendo essa cara de 13 temos é que ser da
equipe também se deve dizer o que quando
nós estamos em viagem e quando estamos
sozinhos não temos ninguém atrás nós nós
temos uma libra lado uma comunicação com
as pessoas muito simples e não se
esqueçam de uma coisa nós temos sempre a
melhoria outra coisa importante em cima
quando aconteceu no iraque
as pessoas quando olham para nós tiramos
em primeiro é muito estranho que quem
somos portanto nunca vai mudar aquilo
que eles querem se eu sentisse querem
perguntar se o nosso lixo está correto
nós falamos do futebol falamos de
arqueologia falamos de tudo e mais
alguma coisa uma vez rio na fronteira
perto do afeganistão em mais chato entre
o irão eo afeganistão e els que em
brincar comigo que não queriam dar o
visto então o que eu disser agora é de
risco em inglês a simpatia de uma
espécie de muitas gírias meus amigos 15
alguns 15 momentos todos olímpico é
proibido entrar no chat mas algumas
amigas minhas não tem nada só que não
estavam todas as balas como fazer
emergir prontos ficaram-lhe e onde não
haja chegando agora quero vir não quer
mas desta vez não vai mais 10 e depois
no física e ou seja todas estas coisas
em viagens são extremamente interessante
por exemplo eu cheguei uma vez o jogo
tinha um país muito complicado e quando
chegam djibuti e seria que não podia
dizer que era juiz
o fotógrafo era muito complicado pra mim
é tudo isso que ela não quer que a volvo
que é que o que eu digo muitas vezes só
que mal a totó graf três câmeras
fotográficas muito complicado resumindo
e concluindo abriram as malas fiquei
três dias no aeroporto só depois vai o
senhor da press na segunda país uma
sexta feira e acabou por não conseguir
arranjar um carro ea todo lado a custo
zero
às vezes as coisas não correm tão mal
como nós já imaginamos como vocês
imaginam não tem muito tempo pra falar
vou responder unicamente a uma pergunta
e depois tem um comboio de 15 minutos
que tem que ir para lisboa
vou continuar votando que de pronto eu
acho que a áfrica vai ter um cnpj
sim pode ser nem isso e é bom
olhem que foi dos meus sonhos outros ser
feliz que eu conheci é tem muito pra
falar sobre ainda já teve 78 vezes vende
mas vou surpreender como em ny e essa
talvez não está preparada para ela é de
manhã as lans eu fiz esta viagem com
ricardo trêpa que é que um lindo norte
que o neto manoel de oliveira e fui com
ela agora é ainda melhor lá há dois anos
pesquisa sobre ainda mais nada eu lá da
tailândia muito longe da índia insiste
em diferentes kers atua em deus quer
vender em documento 45 coisas entrar
semanal e onde aliás entre acendeu e
depois vai semanal de viseu é normal
marcante é e bob dylan que é altamente a
seguir pode fazer a ressalva é me coloca
no chão vi sua santidade o dalai lama
numa linha espiritual voltas calcutá e
se tiver força mas esse imolado mais o
botão equipamente não esqueça da sua
base e quem dela eo beckett esmaltec e
vai sair em 10 dias voltas talvez depois
mais a gestão nunca gestão pode visitar
busca talvez dos lagos mais sagrados e
dos sítios mais interessantes clemente
esquece bomba em algum bairro vai à rua
não esqueça do motor aí que falou em
guarani bom eu já sei quase acabar valor
embora ball que a polícia onze depois
termina talvez cinco estados em a
demanda antes disso o vosso tempo o meu
também é precioso não tem muito mais
tempo para falar mas deixa um conselho
não se esqueçam que o que nem faixa
andar e nós somos aquilo em que
acreditamos
o mais importante nesta via termos mundo
e quando puderem viagem e apanha
viajarem procura estar sozinhos e com os
locais
esta foi minha modesta participação se
precisa de alguma coisa de mim o meu
irmão é no lobito roupas de maio no
lobito arroubos de magos a jesus um dia
muito muito feliz em suas viagens meus
amigos por sorte tê la